it's a very hard time we have I mean
it's a facade but then anger I am about
the whole thing what's happened in
affected a lot of people's life first he
put us through the hell that's why if it
scares his parents and his family
relatives and all those family that they
lost their loved one which III I'm sad
and I share their feeling they lost
their loved one and those people they
got injured why they should something
should happen to them why they should
get injured by the exact so it is not
the good news for the whole America do
you feel shame I did my part to give
medication sent him to school the whole
thing he had his own responsibility for
his own act in life what was my job and
responsibilities I took care of it if I
knew and I noticed something wrong and
I've seen that he's gonna do some and
this kind act arrested that myself or
the call the law enforcement we know
that he had engaged with radical
preachers that he had been following
radical preachers by religion has
nothing to do no religion or background
teaches you to harm somebody killed
someone so it is a loan act so he is
responsible what he's doing not the
religion or the background so I I don't
forgive him what he did that's
unforgettable and unforgivable because
this is we didn't teach him to do this I
taught them to become more educated more
service-oriented to the community yes
how much of a factor do
you think his feelings towards gay
people played in I didn't see any
obvious one I didn't see at all and what
was in the back of his mind I wish she
wasn't alive I could ask him so I I
don't know at all
what was his personal feeling what did
he tell you about the two men he saw
kissing well it was a normal reaction
that he got he sort of like is he go
surprise so would have felt the same it
was a normal reaction but why should I
get my heart I never got mad because
it's a free country everybody has his
own choice to do whatever if the law
allows them the country allows him so
but he was angry disgusted no it was a
normal in surprise What did he say
what's going on here but it upset him I
didn't see a big emotional getting upset
about this do you think there is a
problem with homosexuality well the
first thing I wouldn't want to say is
that club should had good security the
club that for three four hundred people
are coming they should have had good
security if there were a good security
there was a good security
he wouldn't had this opportunity it's
the club's responsibility they should
have that good security and why the law
enforcement came so late
they should've natural neutralize them
quick they should have used some kind of
you know those those you know tear
creating type of bomb or
should without what you call that gas on
him to make him to naturalize him quick
this would not happen do you think there
should have been better security at the
club because there were gay people
inside well obviously if they had that
kind experience they should have had
better security and after this any club
should have security so if someone comes
six people they wanna this psycho people
they wanna or these bad people you want
to come home people inside club they
should protect that people that they
come in the club and do you understand
do you empathize with his do you
empathize with his criticism of
homosexuality I never heard them
criticize and he had no right he knew
that I will not tolerate to interfere in
other people's life so and I wish you or
the life I would ask him why did he do
that
such a horrible actor do you think this
was an act of terror or an act of hate
or an attack on the gay community was it
all of those I think if he was alive I
couldn't had the accurate answer and
he's dead I don't wanna use the guest
why did he do that
why dear why what what was his problem
as far as you know these people coming
in the club see this is a question if it
was alive I would ask him why did he do
that first to harm people and why he
throws life his wife's life as kids and
our deep but he put us through a very
bad situation he not only destroyed
himself he affected all of us
emotionally physically and mentally and
also those people they passed away I'm
very saddened
more than his
because he caused all those sadness and
losing a loved one love and get injured
so if my feeling personal feeling is
responsible the club is responsible for
him not having a good security if there
was a good communication with the
security yet they could have protected
much better the people it's claimed that
he had visited the club more than once
and that he was using a gay dating app
how do you feel if that's the case I I
don't know if he what he was doing and I
wish I didn't know he didn't talk to me
he kept everything for himself if that
was the case are you surprised to hear
he might have been using a gay dating
app I don't know why he was using it to
get that to get there and do something
so I don't know why I wish he was alive
I could ask him because I don't want to
guess what he did was he a very terror
act on on his own people if he had some
personal problem we could have gone
overseas whatever you are doing I
wouldn't be remembering him and how was
he the last time you saw him
it was a just normal relationship what
usual so came in in the span of a time
when so yes that's what this uniform so
nothing surprised me another word he'd
had problems though he was taking
steroids he had challenges in his life
but I'm not the way enough I never seen
him jest he was spending time with the
Sun on the beach walking majority time
when I was talking to him what are you
I'm on the beach walking with my son do
you think he was a man of faith he was
attending the ceremony if a man of faith
yeah you know the religion teaches us
fear of God being responsible towards
this community and to all the people so
you draw the conclusion do you think has
a problem with homegrown terrorism in
America and I'm sure the law enforcement
of the United States very very alert
about this issue and I I don't want in
the future anything happened here in
anything that that's such a good should
get taken care of by law enforcement and
what I see in the past few persons the
police department or the federal law
enforcement they did a wonderful job
they are very alert and they are very
sensitive about this issue and did you
know that the FBI were investigating
your son I was aware of that but what
did you think when you so they did talk
to him the whole thing went away you
knew that he was being investigated by
the FBI did that not raise alarm bells
any well he was there was some other
issue that they all invested gotten
investigated and they all went away well
yeah I was there I was there in there or
some incidents like like a religious
issue or something that what did you say
to him yet those people they were
teasing him the whole thing they got
under 30 you know that he shouldn't be
harassing him he was teasing that job
people on the core tells the other
employee so it is I casted that's a
solving the law enforcement people did a
excellent job they were professional
they never alert in they noticed that so
what what he did now three years later
that he is responsible for his action
and I wish I did notice that would you
describe him as
isn't it would you describe him as an
Islamic extremist it has nothing to do
with Islam
those those killers and they call it
Isis what I heard in the news in a
meeting they are not religious people
they use the name of religion to for
their personal gain show you all the
religion people of faith people of book
if they are really religious they have a
fear of God and follow the religion what
God says what the revelation of the book
is so this is something that I don't
want to include the religion or
background